in the immortal words of redeye brutal
savage rekt that's what this week's best
of is all about now before you guys go
hit the comment section with book callin
you already covered this last week nah
bro we did it the previous episode of
best of focused on the best get rekt
moments in csgo in-game this week we've
opened it up to all the eSports and
we're focusing on that out of game
savagery I repeat out of game savagery
not trash talk there is a difference I
mean you got to know how it is right
sometimes you just got to switch off
that filter turn to the guy next to you
and drop the verbal Smackdown actually
that kind of sounds like a typical day
of the score eSports I'm a huge naughty
fan I love seeing them play I've seen
Dendi do well and I really wish that
they you know played much better
throughout this tournament but I guess
they are back back to being garbage
right now he's not showing anything much
[ __ ] in game he's these real-life but
that he's gonna be in all those quiet as
when the deep fuse is going to come
across
I've got my tickets here I got tickets
to the Korean hype train and I will be
giving them out it's your last chance
first class still available krepo you
let me go ahead I'll go ahead and punch
this for you there you go thank you
money I appreciate you like your SKT
favorite but I think it's more time for
well sometimes in life you lose and
sometimes you face an a so I expected a
pretty easy win absolutely well maybe if
you can't make it in here you can try
out for some North American team garbage
gotta be honest you guys got smashed by
gambit there and what did you take from
that what did you learn from that smash
hey the truth is hot hey hurts it hurts
okay
I'd just like to apologize to all the
viewers who tuned in and had to watch
that North versus heo match no one
should have to put up with that that's
cruel and unusual punishment but we do
have some good matches coming up now so
hopefully this will make up for it [ __ ]
her myself we're all thinking it recent
Rolfing have to be the jerk here but
nobody asked okay supers consistently
just really good he's like always a top
five mid player regardless of the patch
and obviously everyone knows the support
duo is really good I mean is he good is
he like super good mid or just super
good mid compared to you when you played
it expecting is still pretty much dandy
light so okay so joke Dudek smith these
just as good if not a little better than
so Peter you didn't make it to world so
you're practicing your stand-up career
now
don't press empty buttons and I'm just
yeah you do that to me and I just wanted
to like stop and say you you're clever
you're too I commend you on this it
worked on you but we're talking about
Snake Eyes here right and snake eyes are
the top player so I do think that there
is still I think a small chance for LGD
here they go three you know which based
on the quality their players surely pop
right if they can't change you getting
more hair in your head yeah corn I've
prepared a visual representation for
what happened in that game so hope
everyone at home is ready for this
yanker they're just locked into
defensive positions and then suddenly
the value just drops down completely
like a Java news behind is about as
useful as you in the jungle Kobe's
penalty I would be joined here by
merlini but unfortunately he can only do
one job at one so I'm stuck with you
blitz and there's no storm in the game
what do you got for me it's honestly
just incredible being on stage here with
the guy that they brought in case Toby
gets sick blitz I have to ask you as
someone who's never cast in
international Grand Finals what are your
thoughts on the trip
honestly the dress I kind of disagree
for me personally I think that if you
choose a couple material but they're
kind of like the LD of castings are
never really going to get that hot spot
send me a whole pod you are I'm bad
enough to beat hero to Oh Rio MTO who
else virus to Oh blah blah blah
but then lose curious open bracket was
pretty easy I'm not gonna lie pretty
about your loss yeah [ __ ] I was I was
actually a pretty decent keeper in
football
it all went downhill so I just started
playing more video games and now you're
not even in LCS Oh
I'm so sorry I had to yeah let's move on
to the games I just want to say screw
all the casters for not believing in us
and hopefully you guys believe in us in
the playoffs thank you very much
Wow do we have to be such a little
[ __ ] s'alright
hi yeah oh I see such little [ __ ] I
predicted them to win I did at the
beginning of the day but even when under
the bus
don't put me in the same basket as these
guys so final we always deserved here at
the world champions like what are you l
ck game Hollywood better cast sometimes
krepo they have to give you the chance
to actually cast the good team so
welcome to the og and autumn season
final problem for them is Shazam he
turned up and I'm not talking about
because I'm that terrible movie the
shock made in the 90s a terrible movie
for the lounge guys so they didn't want
to see any part up what do you think of
that takes a lot of Steel to say that
brother I'll show you I'll see this
thorn how quickly can you run because
this shot my mystery so you guys Nick as
a sport will challenge you guys in a
couple weeks any game you want you come
to any game not make you eat those words
buddy cuz it's getting better
this is America the Queen well first of
all the analyst desk has nothing like to
worry about they could talk about all
the problems we're having with the video
some blah blah blah whatnot they don't
have they don't know [ __ ] if you ask me
especially Tori what the hell is going
on what are these weirdos talking about
on the desk if you are unfamiliar
fortunately the score eSports does help
you out I love you I love you all very
much don't you don't sugar me I love you
I do I love no sale coming on what I
think about him soon 25-minute video
saying minutes worth of content now
though let's move on I spent five years
of my life living in South Korea and I
loved it but today you know what I'm
gonna be you know people have been
wanting me to cheer for America for
years to protecting American boy today's
not that day
No
[Applause]
they'll be kissing with the Sur action
slacks like [ __ ] me with a [ __ ] you
know I'm trying to be serious like I've
worked like I'm trying like do this I
mean jeez I'm wearing a wig and a
costume and the team's don't pay me to
do anything anymore so here we are
that's great thanks Lex now you work for
me [ __ ] I mean I'm not quite LCS pro
player level Damian either you anymore
that throw would have connected but it
was a hit the hit stun was longer than
flak stun the throw whip congratulations
mark we'll see you in the losers I am
technically undefeated in csgo one B
ones I demolished my fellow supervising
editor who does not play csgo when I was
there in Toronto
[Music]
savage ranked absolutely taken down well
guys that's all we got for you this week
on best of now look if you think we
missed your favorite savage out-of-game
moment truth is probably wasn't that
good thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button